Speaker 1: All right, let's get right into
your emails for the week if you want to send
something in, comment, question, trolling,
critique, whatever, use the email address
info at David Pakman dot com or click on the
contact button at David Pakman dot com.
Either way, it'll all go to the same place.
Let's go through and see what is on the minds
of the people.
That is ultimately what matters.
I heard from Kay who says, Hi, David.
It's been interesting seeing how many, for
lack of a better word, crazies we have living
us among living among us in the US and Australia.
The only thing I want out of this when things
finally settle is an agreement from the right
that if you can argue that no one can tell
you what to do with your body, then at a minimum,
we should all agree that no one can tell a
pregnant person whether or not they can carry
it.
They carry a pregnancy to term.
I don't agree that a fetus is a person, but
if we ignore that position, no one can argue
against abortion that you're taking a life
because your failure to take a vaccine or
wear a mask puts the rest of us fully viable
and already living people at risk.
But I suspect consistency is something right
wingers aren't really bound by.
Keep up the good work.
Appreciate you.
Having guest host rather than no show helps
that I already follow Jessie and Faran.
Yeah.
Listen, Kay, without saying this, this is
the only way to present the hypocrisy, the
hypocrisy we are seeing from the anti choice.
Right with the my body, my choice stuff during
the pandemic.
It is an incredible hypocrisy.
And I want to remind people of something I've
been saying for a long time.
Their stated principles are not sincerely
held in many cases.
It's just the talking point that they believe
gets them to the political outcome they want
most readily.
And when the talking point no longer works
or doesn't apply, all of a sudden, then they
abandon it completely.
They are transparently dishonest in that way.
Let's continue.
Next message is from Matt.
This is just horrifying.
Matt wrote in.
Hi, David.
My mom is a medical doctor in North Dakota.
She told me today that she had a patient who
claims that a different medical provider,
a nurse, told them that the covid-19 vaccine
causes an increase in, quote, non-food cravings
for things like cigarets, alcohol, etc. and
literally in the nurse's notes for that patient
that my mom was reading, the nurse wrote down
exactly that.
She advised the patient against the vaccine
because the patient was trying to quit smoking.
Obviously, this is more anti backstabs, but
neither my mom nor I had heard of this before.
I've heard of this one before.
So I figured it might be interesting to let
you know.
Thanks, Matt.
Yeah.
You know, there's a sort of like the calls
are coming from inside the house type of nuttery
going on.
And to hear that there are medical providers
that are opting against getting vaccinated
where it's allowed, that's extraordinarily
distressing and disturbing.
And then to hear something like, you know,
I don't think the vaccine is right for you
because you want to quit smoking and the vaccine
will make you crave cigarets.
So that's a new reason that they've come up
with not to get vaccinated.
Horrifying stuff.
And as crazy as any of these things sound
to you or me, remember that there are people
for whom this sounds reasonable and that is
maybe the most horrifying part of it all.
Email from Angie Angie wrote to me, Mr Pacman,
of, of course, spelling my last name wrong.
Very common that people who write in to suggest
conspiracy videos don't spell my name correctly,
Mr Pacman.
Take a look at this YouTube video.
I believe that you will see things differently.
This is a video from Dr. Christina Parks that's
been floating around.
I don't even know if Dr Parks is a medical
doctor.
You know, this is another hypocrisy with the
right they love to play coy with.
How does Joe Biden get to be called Dr. Biden
if her doctorate is in education?
And then all of a sudden they have people
commenting on vaccines like that person.
Last week we highlighted who has a Ph.D. in
organizational systems commenting about FDA
approval process.
Anyway, the Christina Parks video has been
floating around.
It is not credible.
It's been debunked.
It is not something I would be paying attention
to.
Let's just put it there.
And I did see the video.
It does it does make it makes me see things
differently in that I'm realizing there are
people who are even more gullible than I previously
believe.
That's what I learned from watching this video
and reading the comments.
Next email is from Diana.
Diana wrote, Can you do a segment of how many
people got covid at Obama's birthday?
How many had covid at the party and made it
a super spreader?
Just thought that it would be great for those
people to know the answer.
People are asking me, hey, what about Obama?
As far as I know, the Obama birthday was not
a super spreader event.
I, however, don't think there's anything special
about Barack Obama.
I said I went to a birthday party a couple
of weeks ago.
Twelve people went, vaccination was required
and a test at the door was required.
My friend got tests and everybody was tested
on the way in.
It felt safe.
It felt responsible.
When I asked Dr. Racaniello about it last
week, he said, you know, even if someone was
incubating, you probably have twenty four
hours of not being contagious, assuming you
got a negative test.
I don't know if everybody at Obama's birthday
was tested.
We've not heard of it as a super spreader
event.
It doesn't mean there might not have been
Cringely Video's release, that that's a totally
different story.
But I don't believe the rules should be different
for Democrats or Republicans.
If you've been watching this show long enough,
you would you would certainly know that.
OK, let's go next to Michael's email.
This I find this one interesting.
Michael wrote to me about the voice mail segment,
and Michael said, David, I would first like
to say I enjoy the show.
I find your temperament soothing on my drive
home from work.
You're funnier than people give you credit
for.
But if you let that go to your head, you will
ruin it.
Choose wisely to the point, sir, I noticed
you seem to have stopped finding the humor
in these ludicrous voicemails you play.
You look drained while they play.
If you don't enjoy it, don't do it.
Got to take care of yourself first, sir.
Either way, I love the content.
Be well.
No, I mean, I sort of play up.
The truth is, Michael, this is actually this
is actually satire.
I'm kind of so desensitized by the completely
out of this world wacky stuff that comes into
the voicemail line line in the email line,
that I really don't have nearly the reaction
to it that I should like.
I should be depressed.
I should be drained by the voicemails and
emails that I'm getting from people.
But for some reason I'm not.
And I think it's that I've become desensitized.
So I think I just kind of play up, you know,
when I'm listening to those voicemails.
But it's not about enjoying it or not enjoying
it or whatever the case may be.
But let me tell you, Michael, I really do
appreciate the concern.
That is a really important thing.
I love that you're concerned about me, but
all is fine.
If at some point I don't want to play the
voicemails, it's as simple as saying no more
voicemails and I will make the decision because
ultimately I am the decider on the show.
OK, last one here.
We're including a hate mail.
I'm including the full, full name of this
person because it's not their real name.
They write to me under a pseudonym, John Smith.
And this individual wrote to me and said,
dude, you're a hack.
Biden left 85 billion military equipment left
behind, including night vision recognition
technology, which has all Afghans who helped
American 30.
I mean, it's you know, I'm reading it with
the grammar that it came in 13 additional
U.S. military casualties.
This was the most one single event f up by
any American president in the history of the
world.
Make that the dumbest effing thing ever done
by a world leader in the history of the world.
That was one sentence continuing.
You support this, then you're an idiot.
You can only hide ignorance for so long.
Biden, already an idiot, took the worst job
an idiot can take.
Now this idiot is on display for the world
to see.
I'm having trouble following who the idiots
are.
What a proud day for a capital l liberals.
Maybe eighty five billion was worth getting
rid of.
Basically Lib Dems, Biden, all members of
the squad.
Thank you all.
Will America make it to the twenty twenty
two elections?
China, Iran and Russia are getting ready to
take the lead in world power.
So there's geopolitical confusion here.
Iran is not in the running here.
To be world superpower at this point in time
could be in the future, but not not right
now.
The question of Joe Biden leaving Afghanistan
is one to which I have an emphatic and definitive
answer.
We had no business being there and I'm thrilled
that Joe Biden got us out.
The arc here is George W. Bush got us in.
We stayed for twenty years.
Obama didn't get us out.
Trump didn't get us out.
Biden got us out.
Were there tactical elements that could have
been better handled?
Yes, but there would have been tactical elements
that could have been better handled if Trump
did it as well.
And when Trump was actually asked to articulate
with Stuart Varney last week on Fox Business
what exactly would have done, would you have
done differently?
What do you make of the specific criticisms
Trump ranted about?
Who knows what?
He had no actual answer.
So I am very happy that Biden got us out.
Eighty five billion is very little relative
to what's been spent, and it is right for
us to be out.
It was, you know, the scrutiny that is being
applied, the getting out over the last month
was never applied to twenty years in Afghanistan.
So, you know, John Smith or whoever, it may
be mad at me if you want, but maybe spend
a little more time on syntax and grammar than
making foreign policy criticisms that you
seem to not fully understand.
All right, my friend, if you have an email,
if you want to be featured in the Friday emails,
right.
To info at David Pakman dot com, I look forward
to hearing from you, but be polite.
Be polite, guys.
Don't be like John.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Sign up at join Pakman dot com, get yourself
instant access.
Plus, when you're a member, you're supporting
the show
Speaker 4: and that's a beautiful thing.
We'll see you that.